[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt ihr
wisst ich liebe hefeteig wirklich über
alles einer meiner lieblings zeige auf
jeden fall vor allem in der süßen
variation
heute gibt es ein zubrot ich hab so was
in ähnlicher variante schon mal gemacht
als zimt und so war es dieses
prachtexemplar
heute habe ich einfach mit peter
kuvertüre mit herren schokolade und
nougat gemacht und dann noch gehobelte
mandeln darüber gegeben also eine
richtig leckere kombination und das
könnt ihr euch so vorstellen man wollte
eine platte aus aus dem hefeteig gibt
alles drauf und die zubereitung ist
supereinfach und am ende darf sich jeder
so ein stück abzupfen und daher kuchen
eben den namenszug brot ich zeig euch
jetzt einmal die zutaten für den
hefeteig und dann geht es gleich los
für den teig brauche ich einen würfel
hefe zwei esslöffel warmes wasser ein
eigelb 80 gramm zucker 500 gramm mehl
250 milliliter milch etwas vanille
extrakt 80 gramm flüssige butter und
einen teelöffel salz
ich nehme jetzt zuerst die hefe und die
wir das gemeinsam mit dem wasser und dem
zucker verrühren
[Musik]
jetzt kommt das hefe gemischt in eine
große schüssel und da gebe ich jetzt das
eigelb das mehl die milch dass vanille
extrakt den übrigen zucker die flüssige
butter und jetzt gebe ich noch das salz
hinzu und kann jetzt daraus etwas sieben
minuten einen geschmeidigen teig kneten
[Musik]
jetzt ist der hefeteig so weiß kann ich
die arbeitsfläche ein bisschen fetten
und den teig zu einer kugel rollen und
ihnen dann abgedeckt eine stunde ruhen
lassen und in der zwischenzeit bereit
ich schon mal die füllung vor und zeigt
euch hier vor noch mal die zutaten dafür
brauche ich 100 gramm herren schokolade
oder zartbitterschokolade 200 gramm 0 60
gramm kalte butter und 100 gramm
gehobelte mandeln
wichtig ist dass die drei zutaten kalt
sind also nur schokolade und butter
die werden jetzt nämlich in würfel
geschnitten und dann fliegt sie auch
noch mal ein dass er richtig schön kalt
sind und in der zwischenzeit kann ich
dann die mandeln nehmen und die mandeln
in einer pfanne ohne fett rösten und
dann noch abkühlen lassen
der hefeteig ist es schön aufgegangen
jetzt kann ich im film
dafür bin ich ein bisschen die
arbeitsfläche und dann rolle ich den
teig zu einem großen rechteck aus
[Musik]
die zubereitung geht jetzt auch super
einfach jetzt schneidet hier aus sechs
gleich breite streifen
das geht jetzt am besten mit meinem
bissig lag ihr könnt aber zum beispiel
auch ein messer benutzen oder einen
pizzaschneider ich habe ich noch ein
paar teig streifen die lege ich es
einfach dazwischen und lege dann diese
sechs bahnen direkt übereinander und
damit ist ein bisschen einfacher geht
halte ich sie jetzt vorher und kann sie
dann besser übereinander stapeln jetzt
nehme ich die kasten backform und
besprühte mit back transfer damit nicht
hängen bleibt
und jetzt setzt sich das erste quadrat
rein und zwar mit der unterseite zur
backform so dass einfach keine füllung
an den rand geht und der rest wird jetzt
einfach rein geschichte und ihr müsst
jetzt nur darauf achten dass am ende
eben auch mit der unterseite nach außen
geschichtet wird damit die füllung nicht
am rand kleben bleibt
[Musik]
ich habe die mandeln ganz vergessen also
wenn ihr daran denkt dann kommen die
mandeln auf jeden fall mit der
schokolade dem new blood und der mutter
mit ihm sind eick ich streue jetzt
einfach ein paar drüber ich wollte ein
paar für drüber ein paar für innen rein
beim nächsten mal mache ich sie alle mit
räumen und jetzt könnt ihr gerne das
droht zb abdecken noch mal eine halbe
stunde aufgehen lassen und dann im
backofen backen so habt ihr etwa eine
bauzeit von etwa 30 bis 35 minuten oder
ihr schießt jetzt in den kalten backofen
so mache ich das ganz gerne weil ich mir
dann das aufgehen nochmal erspare also
jetzt in kalten backofen dann den
backofen an und dann habt ihr einfach
eine etwas längere parkzeit
[Musik]
jetzt ist das brot gebacken und ich kann
es aus der backform herauslösen ich hab
noch kurz abkühlen lassen
ich finde das echt schön
[Musik]
und dann auf stellen hat sich für sie
schon richtig genial wenn ihr möchtet
könnt ihr es gerne so lassen von der
süße herr es ist auch nicht so süß ich
werde jetzt allerdings noch ein bisschen
schokolade darüber geben
ich habe hier 50 gramm peter kuvertüre
gehackt und zwei drittel davon über dem
warmen wasserbad erwärmt bis es flüssig
ist und habe einfach das restliche
drittel zugefügt und jetzt habe ich eine
richtig schöne schokolade die wunderbar
glänzt und das kann ich jetzt hier ein
bisschen darüber träufeln und dann noch
dicker schnee also süßen schnee
verwenden wenn ihr möchtet
[Musik]
und jetzt können wir schon sehr weh ich
fühle mich immer wie frau holle wenn ich
so dass dritten denken dass schneider
das schneiden und ich sehr wäre
[Musik]
der moralische jetzt leider nicht da das
heißt ich muss leider probieren musste
noch mal einkaufen gehen und jetzt kann
ich hier das erste stück so ein bisschen
abzupfen und dann habt ihr diese vielen
verschiedenen schichten hier drin und da
habt ihr doch nun gab dabei und die
gehobelte mandeln also wenn man sie beim
zubereiten nicht vergisst sind sie auch
innen drin und dann könnte das schön auf
essen und mir schmeckt hefegebäck immer
frisch am besten also ganz warm aus dem
backofen könnte jetzt auch den ganzen
kuchen alleine ist und ihr seht schon
der supersoft und richtig luft ich sage
ich glaube ich nicht aber ich es ist
jetzt gleich in ruhe mit einem mit einer
tasse kaffee und wenn ihr das rezept
auch gerne nachmachen möchte dann schaut
auf meinem blog vorbei aufs ellis -
blog.de
da steht alles noch mal ganz genau mein
team und ich werden jetzt in kuchen auf
essen nur murat kriegt leider kein stück
weil er eben nicht da ist aber egal er
mag ja eh nicht so viel süßes essen
für ihn mache ich dann später was mit
job also bis zum nächsten mal
so greift alle zu
[Musik]